[Musica]
buongiorno ho deciso di iniziare con
questa slide perché mi dà la sensazione
del tempo che ci veste costantemente e
trasforma nostro presente in passato
quello che io sto dicendo in questo
momento se l'è già portato via la
corrente
io sono un appassionato di fendi
fantascienza mi piace l'idea di poter
modificare il tempo di tirarlo
accorciarlo però purtroppo noi questo
non possiamo farlo siamo però da
millenni e negli ultimi 100 anni
diventati davvero molto bravi a
misurarlo la misura del tempo se ci
pensate
fa parte della nostra vita di tutti i
giorni dagli appuntamenti i sistemi di
geolocalizzazione che funzionano
ovviamente con il tempo poi lasciamo
stare il capitolo mappe che potrebbe
anche non portarli dove volete
lo possiamo considerare un metronomo
assoluto della nostra vita non a
religioni non ha confini
ma ci posiziona perfettamente nel nostro
fiume del tempo che sia una una
posizione è presente e passata e futura
a differenza del regno animale noi umani
viviamo dipendendo dal tempo vi faccio
un esempio alla vostra sinistra c'è la
mia radiosveglia radio controllata alla
vostra destra la mia gatta e daisy non è
venuta benissimo perché tutte le volte
che cercavo di fare la foto veniva ad
annusare l'obiettivo entrambe mi
svegliano tutti i giorni alla stessa ora
mi dimenticasse di mettere la sveglia ci
penserebbe daisy per spegnere la sveglia
preme un pulsante per far smettere daisy
vi assicuro che sa essere veramente
antipatico
devo darle da mangiare quando c'è il
cambio da ora legale ora solare la
sveglia fa da sola lei si no ci vogliono
decine di giorni per regolarla inoltre a
un altro difetto
lei non distingue giorni della settimana
il sabato e la domenica per le tutti i
giorni sono uguali quindi tutti i giorni
lei mi sveglia la stessa ora se il
sabato la domenica volesse dormire un
attimo di più
vai verrebbe comunque a svegliarci
questo perché perché vi faccio questo
discorso perché la misura del tempo mi
ha sempre affascinato avvicinato mio
papà che l'ha trasmessa me e poi anche
mio fratello siamo una famiglia di
orologiai e quindi io vi racconterò un
po la nostra storia quando parlo del mio
mestiere
l'immagine mentale che ha la maggior
parte delle persone è proprio questa un
banco da lavoro con diversi pezzi sparsi
qua e là con una lucina utensili antichi
e una persona anziana che lavora capelli
bianchi perché l'anziano trasmette
saggezza esperienza in realtà ci sono
anche tanti orologiai giovani e anche
delle donne che fanno questo mestiere e
quelle che una volta erano le botteghe
si sono trasformate in laboratori
ecco questa
è la foto di una delle aree del mio
laboratorio nostro laboratorio noi la
consideriamo l'area pulita dove si fanno
i montaggi dove c'è anche un'area
purificata dalla polvere come vedete il
banco da lavoro molto cambiato sono
cambiati gli utensili ci sono computer
nell'ultima generazione proprio
specifici per il nostro lavoro e questo
è un cambiamento che ha portato
vantaggio a tutti in particolare agli
utenti finali
dovete pensare che papa ha iniziato a
lavorare a 16 anni in un periodo per
l'orologeria abbastanza importante
quindi si è affacciato agli anni
cinquanta importante perché all'epoca
l'orologiaio era colui che costruiva gli
orologi ma non esisteva in realtà una
figura di orologiaio riparatore c'erano
per lo più dei degli esperti di
meccanica che facevano un po di tutto ti
paravano gli orologi ma riparavano anche
le macchine fotografiche riparavano le
pendole riparavano le macchine da cucire
e spesso in contesti diversi
anche perché i primi orologi sono sì
comparsi nelle orologerie ma anche nelle
ottiche per via dell'attinenza con gli
strumenti di misura
pensate che i primi orologi da polso da
donna sono comparsi alla fine dell
ottocento inizio novecento
perché le donne non avevano il taschino
ed erano dei piccoli gioielli da tenere
al polso per vedere gli orologi da polso
sull'uomo
dobbiamo aspettare la prima guerra
mondiale dove ovviamente per esigenze di
guerra non era possibile estrarre dal
taschino vedere l'ora e quindi hanno
incominciato a metterlo al polso
immaginate i piloti d'aereo stanno anno
la cloche a cetara togliersi impossibile
per incominciare a trovare la produzione
industriale però dobbiamo aspettare la
fine del secondo conflitto
quindi il periodo storico degli anni 50
e stato un periodo un po rivoluzionario
incominciavano produrre i movimenti in
serie e papa si è affacciato a questo
mondo che per lui non sempre
appassionato e tutt'oggi la passione con
dei principi ben saldi che sono un po le
colonne portanti della nostra azienda e
che continuiamo a mantenere tutt'oggi e
sono serviti per portare avanti il
nostro business
uno di questi è il concetto di pioniere
un pioniere è colui che scopre che
investe in se stesso con coraggio che
traccia i sentieri prima degli altri e
lui che traccia il sentiero perché gli
altri poi vengono dietro e lui
come anche altri orologiai ha
incominciato a pensare di rapportarsi
con le fabbriche di orologi in svizzera
per capire se c'era la possibilità di
creare sinergia come orologiaio in zona
ovviamente rapportandosi con delle
aziende che avevano incominciato a
produrre ma che sostanzialmente mai si
sarebbero pensate già di trovare degli
orologiai disponibili a fare il servizio
in molti casi anche se avevano mai
pensato
mi dicevano come mai iniziamo ora
vendere cosa ci importa
in realtà è stato proprio questo il
periodo in cui si sono tessuti migliori
rapporti che a tutt'oggi noi manteniamo
perché il servizio è parte fondamentale
di tutto qua di tutto quello che io
ritengo un cerchio che si deve chiudere
il produttore allunga le mani sul
territorio con il servizio forma i
tecnici questi offrono il servizio ai
clienti finali e la soddisfazione del
servizio permette di rafforzare il brand
quanti di voi si sono mai chiesti quando
comprano qualcosa
oddio cosa mi succederà se per caso si
rompe perché io non voglio portare
sfortuna
effettivamente le cose possono
funzionare molto bene ma prima o poi
qualcosa si rompe per cui non siamo
eterni neanche noi
ed in questo contesto è riuscito a
creare i presupposti uno dei presupposti
principali per la creazione della
propria azienda
ovviamente questo è uno degli
ingredienti investire nella conoscenza
un principio secondo me fondamentale e
dal mio punto di vista va visto a 360
gradi
mi spiego non necessariamente nelle
vostre competenze ma alimentando la
vostra voglia di conoscenza e
soprattutto il vostro sapere
guardando oltre quello che è il vostro
lavoro
a me è capitato spesso di fare questo di
frequentare ad esempio dei corsi che non
sono attinenti con il mio mestiere
vi svelo un segreto prima di essere
orologiaio io ho studiato informatica è
proprio il fatto di aver sviluppato
determinate attitudini di analisi mi è
molto servito in azienda per pianificare
proprio i flussi di lavoro e irrobustire
soprattutto quello che era il lavoro che
aveva già iniziato papa
siate innovatori vabbè uno dice parolona
magica grandiosa però l'innovazione si
fa anche con piccole cose per esempio
noi quando io ovviamente io ho sempre
vissuto nel laboratorio di papà perché
papa aveva il laboratorio attinente la
casa adesso abbiamo una sede nuova però
è chiaro cioè alla fine c'ero sempre in
mezzo e bisogna tener conto che
all'inizio le riparazioni venivano
gestite con le buste scritte a mano il
registro del carico e scarico tutte
procedure che funzionavano ma portavano
via molto tempo quindi abbiamo
introdotto dei processi di lavoro dei
workshop che ci permettono attraverso
barcode e comunque l'utilizzo
dell'informatica di non sottrarre tempo
a quello che facciamo meglio il nostro
lavoro non solo sono parlato del flusso
del beth ingresso uscita dalle
riparazioni ma ad esempio abbiamo
irrobustito un sistema che permette di
tenere sempre informati i nostri clienti
sulla situazione delle riparazioni che
manda degli sms se l'orologio è pronto
viene manda anche altri se per caso si
fossero dimenticati di venirlo a
prendere ma non solo per i clienti
business quelli che si rivolgono a noi
dato che noi facciamo servizio anche le
gioiellerie per esempio c'è un portale
che permette di interagire con noi 24
ore su 24 sette giorni su sette anche
quando noi non siamo al lavoro per
questo perché perché è fondamentale dare
il miglior servizio al cliente
sempre nello spirito dell'innovazione
noi qualche anno fa abbiamo pensato da
una nuova avventura imprenditoriale
ne parlavamo poco fa i corsi la
formazione mio fratello ed io abbiamo
fatto dei corsi di modellazione
tridimensionale cad e quindi abbiamo
acquisito in azienda dalle stampanti 3d
e anche delle macchine delle frese
tridimensionali quindi dei piccoli cnc
uno magari potrebbe dire sei un
orologiaio cioè cosa ti servono questi
mezzi
invece sono stati fondamentali perché
siamo in grado di costruirci dei piccoli
attrezzati
lo facciamo in proprio e abbiamo anche
creato delle macchine che sono esclusive
la nostra esperienza nel nostro lavoro
esperienza avendo a che fare con
l'utenza
noi siamo ovviamente affacciati al
pubblico al cliente finale
ascoltiamo le esigenze e questa
esperienza non abbiamo anche riversata
in una nuova idea imprenditoriale
abbiamo creato una nostra linea di
orologi disegnati progettati da noi
creati da noi frutto della grande
esperienza che abbiamo acquisito con i
clienti chi mi diceva non riesco a
vedere bene l'ora perché le lancette
sono troppo piccole che mi diceva non
vedo la data ma spesso quando
consegniamo gli orologi medica magari
commenta la data non la vedo quindi
questi sono stati degli input importanti
per noi
esperienza mi racconta un aspetto ci
sono dei clienti ed una percentuale
neanche tanto esigua che sono soliti
acquistare degli orologi dalle
prestazioni eccezionali tipo in grado di
andare
non so la profondità abissali
incredibili oppure essere sottoposti ai
campi magnetici molto forti urti
vibrazioni che poi sono soliti non usare
l'orologio in questi contesti perché
hanno paura di rovinarlo come semi
comprasse un bellissimo fuoristrada ma
avessi paura di fare un vialetto
sterrato che cosa ci hanno dato questi
clienti ci hanno fatto intuire che
esiste una nicchia di mercato dove manca
un prodotto perché l'innovazione si fa
anche andando a colmare una nicchia di
mercato dove un prodotto manca seguite
le vostre passioni
questa secondo me è la cosa più
importante in assoluto perché lo vedo in
papa che per lui lavora è stata una
passione grandissima e anche sono
emozionato nel dirlo anche noi figli lo
seguiamo
seguite le vostre passioni importante
perché riuscirete a lavorare senza
fatica alimentate la fiammella che sta
accesa dentro di voi riuscirete
veramente a oltrepassare qualsiasi
ostacolo
noi abbiamo fatto sempre tesoro di
questo modo di pensare e anno dopo anno
ogni volta ci raggiunge una nuova idea
se ne discute in azienda
ed infatti stiamo in procinto proprio
nella prossima settimana di lanciare
anche un progetto sulle piattaforme di
crowdfunding quello che posso dirvi oggi
siate più neri investita in conoscenza
siate innovatori eseguite le vostre
passioni ma soprattutto ricordatevi che
il tempo e la più grande risorsa che vi
è stata data e io personalmente vi
auguro di saperla consumare con saggezza
grazie
[Applauso]